OK, you guys have to see this, this is going
to give you sort of a glimpse into how sick
and deranged a huge part of the country is.
Trump started swarming a vote counting location
at the 26th center in Detroit,
Michigan, yesterday to furiously
and defiantly and outrageously demand that votes
not be counted now simultaneously. They were
swarming Arizona polling places saying count
votes. We'll get to that later. The hypocrisy,
we need a little more time for. Check this out.
This is video from Analise Frank on Twitter.
And yes, the chant you are about to
hear is stop the votes. Oh, oh, oh, oh,
people weren't just outside, here is a picture
from the same analyst, Frank Reporter in Detroit
from inside. And as she describes it, these
trumpets were yelling about election integrity
and how votes should stop being counted
immediately. Here's more video of these
Stop the Count chants.
Dr..
Do you realize how mind numbingly stupid
we look to every country around the world,
we look like idiots and there's a lot to what
happened yesterday in Detroit. It was not a
spontaneous demonstration. Chad Livengood,
who's a reporter in Detroit as well, posted
a screenshot of an email that was sent yesterday
morning by a so-called coalition's director named
Sean Moshinsky, which went out to Republican
voters telling them, come to the Tarkoff Center
in Detroit to be vote challengers. And then this
is exactly what went down. And the right seems to
think that it is some kind of radical leftist idea
to count every legal ballot in a democracy. Donald
Trump retweeted just moments ago. I don't have
this for you, but you can find it on his Twitter.
A statement from the Nevada attorney general,
Adam Laxalt, claiming that, hey, listen,
if it weren't for mail in ballots in Nevada, Trump
would have won, which, of course, ignores that
mail in ballots are legal ballots in the sense
that they are ballots from voters who votes.
It's unbelievable the perversion of democracy that
they so casually attempt. And when this is all
said and done, I am really interested in what the
talking points will be when people mention that
counting ballots is part of democracy, not a
perversion of it. And Republicans desperately try
to stop the counting of votes. It's going to
be some version of, well, we weren't allowed to
look at each ballot. We don't know if those were
legitimate ballots or they were just finding fake
ballots. That's sort of the argument we heard Rudy
Giuliani make yesterday. Conservatives will claim
that they were just trying to make sure all the
ballots were legitimate. And every time, you know,
for the last four years it's happened, what,
a hundred times that I find myself wondering,
how are they going to justify this absurdity? This
is beyond justification. Trump with the Sharpie on
the hurricane map or what? This this one has to
be beyond justification. And then I look in the
comment sections in the pro Trump enclaves of the
Internet, and then I say, oh, that's how they're
going to justify it, OK? They always found a
way. And in fact, I keep reading comments from
Trump talking about deadlines for ballots that
they think are being violated. The deadlines for
counting votes are decided at the state level.
The states that are still counting haven't
reached the deadline. It's very simple. The only
constitutional deadline is that by December 14th,
when the electors officially vote, the count must
be done. People who don't support democracy do
this. Now, meanwhile, in Detroit, you had stopped
the count. Protesters in Michigan in I'm sorry,
in Arizona, you had start the count protesters.
And we're going to talk about that next.